I grew up around sled dogs and rabbits
and so that sort of visual and and
physical fabric is what makes up my life
world I'm definitely interested in
creating work that plays with the idea
of these perceived boundaries between
humans and nature and showing those
interconnections and poetic ways that
are unnerving sometimes and beautiful I
have this piece titled ornament in which
I have these three hermit crabs crawling
on the back of my head and there is an
ornate braid running around the back
the crabs themselves are fairly ornate
and so I'm really interested in the
human body becoming a landscape for
these other organisms it reflects our
human desire to make visual sense of the
natural world I see us as being a part
of nature our bodies are colonized by
bacteria we're not these clothes systems
we exist as microcosms universes so I
think you know we are nature and
everything that we create is a product
of nature as well
[Music]
you